ou est-ce qu'on est aujourd'hui on n'est
pas la maison bien kg et de la brique
non on est aujourd'hui à paris dans un
lieu qui est très sympa quand vous allez
découvrir lors d'une interview c'est
aujourd'hui un sujet qui a réalisé en
partenariat avec huawei huawei venu me
voir et m'a dit tiens monsieur dreux on
aimerait par les deux harmonies os on
aimerait parler de la galerie on
aimerait parler de tout notre écosystème
je leur dis bah bien évidemment on va y
aller c'est parti on va se faire
aujourd'hui une interview de stéphane
curtelin vous allez tout savoir vous
allez être incollable parce que vous me
poser beaucoup de questions en
commentaire on va tous regarder
aujourd'hui ensemble toutes les
questions sont là la regarde et on peut
même se faire un petit éventail alex
très pratique jeu même faire de l'air
parce qu'il fait très chaud aujourd'hui
et surtout on va se poser ces questions
aujourd'hui cette question voir un petit
peu plus si affinités à stéphane
curtelin vous êtes prêts c'est parti on
y danse
[Musique]
stéphane pour présenter rapidement toi
tu es site où sont bâties de fiches
directeur marketing comme tu meurs
business group de huawei voilà c'est ça
la partie des produits grand public en
fait on attaque directement les
questions j'ai une première question est
posée depuis les sanctions américaines
vos nouveaux smartphones et tablettes
n'ont plus accès aux services google
comme alternative vous avez développé
les web mobileme si ce qu'on appellera
les hms est ce que tu peux nous les
présenter et nous dire ou es ce que vous
avez dans leur déploiement en france
alors les well services iis et l'accès
aux services dont vous avez besoin qu'on
a créé par nous-mêmes pour justement
remplacer les google mobile service 6-6
webservices si ça permet d'avoir accédé
à quoi c'est quoi ces services dont on a
besoin les applications mobiles les
applications qu'on a sur son smartphone
donc ça permet désormais à 173 me
l'application dans le monde d'être
disponible sur notre propre store
d'applications cloud violent et c'est
l'occasion d'ailleurs de reconnaître le
travail fait par plus de 5 millions de
développeurs dans le monde qui ont
rejoint justement cette aventure de la
world girls c'est aussi en plus des
applications mobiles de plus en plus des
services proposés par huawei donc ses
parents pour wii music on est en train
aussi développer de plus en plus un
service de cartographie qui s'appelle
pétales maps donc l'histoire continue
dans ce sens là ça que les consommateurs
sont android y sont habitués aux
services de google ça peut être une
crainte pour les consommateurs de se
dire ok on va abandonner d'un côté les
gms les google mobile service sise au
profit des web mobile services alors
qu'est ce que tu dirais aux utilisateurs
pour les convaincre de venir sur votre
propre service et quels sont les
avantages mais aussi aujourd'hui les
inconvénients voir les limites qu'on
peut retrouver avec les hms alors la
question est très légitime et c'est bien
qu'on puisse la bordée ce que je leur
dirai c'était les utilisateurs ou futurs
utilisateurs s'est déjà essayée pour se
rendre compte que justement cette web
galerie bâti sur ch msi web et le
service apporte vraiment des réponses
pour les usages du quotidien ils vont
pouvoir retrouver les applications les
plus populaires ils vont pouvoir
retrouver aussi des applications qui ne
sont pas développées en france mais je
pense notamment aux facebook instagram
snap chatte twitter tik tok qui sont
parmi les plus populaires aussi donc on
a vraiment maintenant un ensemble de
solutions pour répondre aux besoins
légitimes justement puis ça fait parti
de l'utilisation de son smartphone au
quotidien sa vie pour attirer les
consommateurs en nombre il faut beaucoup
d'applications qui correspondent à leurs
besoins comme tu disait très justement à
l'instant sur vos smartphones et sur vos
tablettes les applications 10 sont
disponibles comme tu le disais dans
votre catalogue d'applications qui
s'appelle la galerie les catalogues
d'applications concurrents occupe déjà
beaucoup les développeurs alors ma
question elle se trompe plutôt du côté
un peu développeurs quelle stratégie et
quels outils vous avez mis en place pour
emmener les développeurs à venir codé
spécifiquement pour la virer alors notre
envie c'est de proposer les solutions de
probablement les plus ouvertes et plus
favorable aux développeurs alors comment
un exemple huawei dans le monde a mis à
disposition un milliard de dollars dans
un programme qui s'appelle shining star
pour inciter justement à développer dans
la web galerie sur les web services pour
revenir aux applications françaises qui
touche tout le monde les équipes locales
dont je fais partie travaille avec nos
partenaires alors les partenaires c'est
le figaro cbfm c'est my tf1 c'est le
crédit mutuel c'est etc etc pour
justement mettre à disposition de ses
partenaires petits et grands soit des
ressources humaines pour les aider avec
des développeurs soient des ressources
financières pour financer justement
cette migration sur les web mobile
service c'est à la fois pour le futur ce
programme shining star qui est au niveau
mondial lancé et également au quotidien
en local en france des équipes proches
des partenaires pour les applications
françaises pour les aider à développer
donc c'est très concret tu me parles
d'un milliard de dollars est ce qu'on
arrive à savoir quel est le budget qui
arrivent en france là les clés de
répartition ou pas alors en fait ce
milliard de l'ain il est proposé et
après c'est à chacun de candidater pour
sa prochaine application parce que ça
que je fais bien distinction entre
les applications qui existent déjà ou là
on va les aider avec injustement les
équipes locales lassé des ressources au
cas par cas soit on passe du temps avec
elle pour on va leur apporter des
ressources financières pour les aider
justement a développé par eux mêmes et
là c'est plus un appel aux futurs
développeurs aux futures de
développement ou futures applications
pour qu'ils pensent également à nous et
se dire tiens moi je veux lancer
nouvelles applications ben pourquoi pas
me lancer sur la web galerie justement
effet rappelle candidater pour avoir une
partie du chemin de ce financement après
le financement il est évalué en fonction
des besoins développement et on en
revient justement au web mobile service
6 c koi derrière les wasaïs ce sont des
kits cette équipe qui saura quoi faire
des notifications du paiement en ligne à
faire la cartographie c'est en fait une
boîte à outils qui va être utilisé par
les développeurs et plus cette boîte à
outils a besoin d'être complète non plus
le financement va être important et ça
ça vous permet d'avoir un vrai coup
d'accélérateur pour permettre de
développer aujourd'hui la galerie le 14
d'applications également les webbys a
réussi ce break tout à fait c'est ce qui
nous a entre autres permis d'avoir plus
de 1200 application française déjà
disponibles dans notre store et qui
répondent je vais citer l'exemple aux
besoins d'information besoin de voyages
aux besoins paiement besoin les besoins
qu'on retrouve dans une heure dans un
monde d'applications mobiles alors je
compare justement des différentes
applications qu'on peut retrouver pour
permettre de se projeter concrètement
quelles sont les applications qu'on peut
retrouver aujourd'hui sur la galerie
quelles sont les applications on pourra
retrouver prochainement sur la galerie
et qu'est ce que tu dirais aux
consommateurs qui sont habitués encore
pour revenir aux gms qui utilisent gmail
qui utilisent google maps qui ont un
agenda google et pourquoi pas leur
maison neste qui est connecté aux
étudiants alors c'est une très bonne
question du coup je vais commencer par
répondre à la dernière parce que ça soit
que ça fait aussi partie du quotidien si
par exemple j'ai utilisation de google
maps ou de youtube qui sont vraiment des
purs applications google donc là en
effet on a plusieurs solutions on a ce
qu'on appelle la solution des web apps
web apps c'est quoi ces jeux créés tout
simplement un raccourci sur mon
smartphone qui va m'amener sur le
navigateur google maps et en responsive
comme on dit c'est à dire qu'elle va
détecter que vous accédez à google maps
sur votre navigateur chrome ou n'importe
lequel et va l'adapter au format du
smartphone est donc là à travers cette
webapp vous allez retrouver l'ensemble
des usages que vous avez sur
l'application native âge donne un
exemple si vous avez mis sur google maps
favoris vos restaurants où tout ce que
voulait visiter vous allez retrouver
youtube musique vous allez retrouver
votre playlist et ainsi de suite donc il
ya vraiment une solution qui est très
concrète qu'est celle ci gmail par
exemple c'est pareil ça peut être
embarqué dans notre propre système
webmail qui en fait qui va embarquer le
client gmail à l'intérieur ou autrement
retrouvez aussi accès à gmail en passant
à nouveau par le par le browser par le
navigateur voudrais qu'on parle
maintenant d'harmonie os alors il ya
quelques mois vous présente hier un os
qui est votre système d'exploitation qui
s'inscrit dans la continuité de votre
écosystème vous avez présenté déjà il ya
un petit moment également alors
qu'apporte harmonie os ou est-ce que
vous en êtes dans son développement et
puis est-ce que le développement
d'harmonie os a été quelque part un peu
freinée par les sanctions américaines
harmonie os c'est un projet fantastique
pourquoi parce que c'est tout simplement
notre ambition notre vision qui est
vraiment dans cette vision à long terme
indépendamment d'ailleurs des problèmes
avec l'administration américaine que
nous regrettons évidemment il ya une
vision qui est antécédentes à sousse et
ses complications la de ces problèmes là
qui est d'apporter des solutions dans le
monde pour connecter les personnes et
les organisations et les maisons donc
dans cette vision des télécommunications
avancées il ya l'idée aussi de
l'internet des objets d'intégrer
internet des objets on a tous remarqué
qu'on a de plus en plus d'objets
connectés et donc harmonie wells pour
nous c'est ni plus ni moins notre
ambition que de proposer un os de
troisième génération alors pourquoi
troisième génération très simple pour se
refaire les trente dernières années
d'abord on avait un système exploitation
sur les pc ça a échappé à personne mais
c'était quelque chose de centrer sur un
ou des pc ensuite sont arrivés les
smartphones là aussi il ya eu 1 puis le
deuxième os dédié aux smartphones mais
encore une fois c'est est dédié à un
produit et puis on se rend compte que on
collecte de plus en plus donc
aujourd'hui c'est encore assez fragmenté
quand on arrive à appéré son smartphone
avec des enceintes on est content dit
ouais ça a marché c'est encore parfois
une petite surprise et nous ce qu'on
veut c'est que ce soit plus une surprise
c'est que ce soit quelque chose de
complètement fluide et donc de passer
d'un univers fragmenter un univers
connectés et donc c'est l'entrée qu'on a
déjà tous senti dans l'internet des
objets l'internet des objets on se rend
compte qu'à l'avenir on aura pas qu'un
produits connectés on a déjà plusieurs
en as well as partie vit le smartphone
est dans cette histoire de smart device
on arrive vite à avoir plusieurs objets
l'ambition c'est de passer d'un système
d'exploitation centré sur un produit un
système et ses passions qu'ils soient
distribués je vais illustrer sa
des produits avec uniquement 128 ko de
mémoire
pourront avoir des codes harmonie os ça
veut dire que tu prends un exemple qui
peut paraître trivial mais on peut les
multiplier à l'infini une ampoule
une cafetière pourra connecter on pourra
la piloter même si elle a une mémoire
très limité c'est ouvrir des
perspectives sur cet internet des objets
avec un os de troisième génération et
c'est vraiment ça l'ambition de
d'harmonie os sur le marché du
smartphone il ya deux acteurs majeurs
aujourd'hui on a d'un côté apple avec
ios ou d'un autre côté google avec
android est encore de la place pour un
nouvel os et en quoi harmonie os va être
différent des autres systèmes
d'exploitation et qu'est ce qui va venir
apporter plus on pense en effet qu'il ya
vraiment une place pour cela parce qu'il
ya cette idée d'apporter une solution
pour l'avenir pour ceux en tant que
système et passion troisième génération
les autres os convient de citer existe
déjà nous on veut aller plus loin en
proposant cette interconnexion est aisé
fluide intuitive au quotidien et pour
donner un exemple on relance la notion
de super device c'est à dire qu'il n'y
aura plus a besoin de vraiment
configurer façon parfois un peu délicate
d'appairer les produits mais on aura une
vision une interface qui va vous montrer
votre produit sur lequel vous êtes en
train d'agir et les produits satellites
qui pourraient apparaître et ils
apparaîtront par eux mêmes c'est à dire
que l'idée c'est que je suis en mobilité
je rentre chez moi mon smartphone va
détecter les produits harmonie os
compatible harmonie os autour de moi et
va me les proposer naturellement j'ai à
dire spontanément si on vous parlait
pour l'année pour pour la technologie et
donc après je choisis c'est là que se
sera pas envahissant c'est moi qui vais
choisir je rentre tiens on propose la
télévision ce qui existe déjà on a notre
huawei vision qui est disponible en
chine ab je peux la paire et ça se fait
naturellement d'un seul coup de doigt
sur mon smartphone et après l'histoire
continue sur ma télé ce que l'on veut
apporter cette aisance et sa
interopérabilité et c'est pour ça qu'on
insiste sur le fait qu harmonie os est
un univers très ouverts tire ça qu'on
veut être particulièrement ouvert aux
développeurs est favorable aux
développeurs en les soutenant
financièrement en les accueillant avec
les équipes locales et en justement en
envisageant l'avenir ensemble de ce que
tu me décris j'ai l'impression
effectivement qu'il vous mettait les
moyens à 300% pour que wes aujourd'hui
incontournable dans le domaines de
l'univers connecté avec le smartphone au
centre et on voit tous les appareils
autour moi ça va je teste beaucoup de
vos appareils je vois très bien que le
faire collecter très facilement mon un
écart en pro qu'il a communiqué avec mon
moniteur qui va communiquer avec mon
macbook avec mon mec view avec bref non
mais pas tout communique très bien
ensemble mais pour autant j'ai
l'impression qu'il manque encore un
petit quelque chose pour qu'une adoption
grand public est ce que c'est le cas
tout de suite est-ce qu'il faut encore
rassurant un peu le consommateur parce
qu'il faut venir chercher le
consommateur ce qu'il faut venir
chercher les développeurs pour arriver
sur une solution grand public oui et je
dire une adoption en masse c'est une
très bonne question et ça permet de
rappeler que c'est une histoire qui est
en cours qu'on est en train de bâtir
ensemble justement avec les développeurs
donc comme tu l'a très bien mentionné il
ya déjà des choses qui marche très très
bien et déjà des solutions au quotidien
et c'est pour ça qu'on continue de
vendre des smartphones aujourd'hui le
week-end dernier week-end prochain pour
noël il va se vendre le nova 9 il va se
vendre des produits qui sont disponibles
non seulement online mais en plus dans
les magasins donc c'est à dire qu'à des
consommateurs qui va les acheter et ça
se passe très bien en revanche c'est
vrai que c'est encore à construire ce
que je décris c'est une vision de
l'avenir qui va se développer se
battirent mois après mois semaine après
semaine et c'est ce qu'on a fait si on
prend un peu de recul il ya deux ans il
n'y a rien dans la bo de galeries qui
correspondent aux français aujourd'hui
de plus de 1200 applications qui sont
disponibles ça nous a pris un an et demi
elle est presque deux ans harmonie os
qu'on a commencé c'était il ya quelques
mois en france avec la tablette avec une
montre à la watch froid et ça va
continuer ça va s'accélérer en effet
2022 et 2023 voie d année très
importante pour va faire grandir cet
écosystème de façon très concrète en
plus de ce qui existe déjà au quotidien
merci beaucoup ses fans allaient plaisir
merci aura lien merci à toi c'est
intéressant on va continuer à suivre ça
dans les temps à venir bien évidemment
je continuerai à tester avec plaisir vos
produits puis on va voir l'évolution qui
va arriver comme tu le disais pour cette
année déjà 2021 2022 et puis voilà ça
dans l'est dans les années à venir quant
à vous je vous remercie d'avoir suivi
cette interview j'espère que ça vous
aura intéressé si vous avez des
questions des suggestions des îles et
des interrogations vous mais tous marqué
en bas en commentaire et on se retrouve
très bientôt c'est en formant un petit
peu à part mais c'est très intéressante
pour faire cette interview avec stéphane
pour l'espagne voit bien
[Musique]
du coup